kennen sie diesen mann und wer ist er ja
eigentlich das werde ich für sie
herausfinden also vielleicht
[Musik]
hallo
es war endlich mal freue mich für mich
ich werde auch auf ihre stimme ja ich
wohne ja hier hat mit der wahl
beschäftigt deswegen die frage wer sind
sie noch mal
also im feld selber nichts ein was sie
unterscheidet
irgendwas
ja also der dings weise schon mal nicht
keine ahnung wer war das
wie kann man die beiden
spitzenkandidaten auseinanderhalten ist
es unfassbar schwer wir sind beide
ziemlich
große brille sehen optisch
72 kartoffeln einfach
denn ich bin der n katholische mit
kindern der andere war auch eine andere
ausrede nicht leide brillenträger java
studium tatsächlich also ich könnte
jetzt nicht auseinander halten denn
nicht nur die infos kriege man weiß im
besten alter geborene nrw katholisch
abitur studium york ist verheiratet
vater brillenträger ex-minister landes
position spitzenkandidat bist dich nicht
fest ist keine angst bei jäger camps mir
ist natürlich
wichtig machen also kann ich mir merken
kleiner wichtig macher und der ist
natürlich
okay also habe ich noch nie gesehen
welches logans gehören zu welcher partei
energie sicher und bezahlbar und der
andere für bezahlbare energie stimmt das
ist herzig fast gleich an zusammen für
ein starkes land
oder unser land von morgen dann ist das
die cdu welcher davon
unser land
das war spd
sicher und bezahlbar wird die partie
zurück ja ja das war der cdu slogan
müssen sie doch hendrik wüst wählen wer
war denn das gerade der hier ins land
war thomas tings wie hieß das ein
vernünftiger politik ag und die ukraine
scheiße rhein ziehen lässt so langsam
taucht im internet auf das habe keiner
wiederherstellt das habe ich von anfang
an gesagt na aus keiner kommt reisen
alle sind entwickler und estland alle 17
und jetzt macht das militär ok bleiben
wir doch lieber bei ihrem fachgebiet
kartoffeln geld sie haben ja gerade das
foto gemacht wissen sie wer das war das
ist der hexer ja hallo
[Gelächter]
sogar
jetzt habe ich sie sind der neue
bachelor
ja jetzt werden wir sicher dieser mann
der hier gerade blumen verteilt hat
wissen sie wer das war
dann können sie ja gar nicht wählen da
muss ich ihnen die blumen leider wieder
abnehmen weil die waren nur für
wahlberechtigte und ihr habt ja in
holland blumen genug
neben halo
kennen wir uns nicht irgendwoher also
sie sind von heute schon ich freue mich
sehr dass sie in nordrhein westfalen
sind hallo
haben sie gehört wer hier gleich
hinkommt nein thomas kutschaty
leute das ist ein bisschen leer hier im
kleingartenverein oder die mittagspause
ich glaube sie liegen alle noch in der
hütte drin und nachmittag haben sie
gehört wer hier gleich vorbei kommen
thomas kutschaty
ihr spitzenkandidat konnten wir noch
nicht verraten wie er heißt hendrik
düster das sinn macht das ist henrik wie
hendrik weber der lange dünne ja wer
lange dünne ja so jetzt weiß ich wer sie
sind hendrik wüst viel glück im
wahlkampf
und weist zwar immer noch nicht wer wer
ist aber wahlgewinner bin ich trotzdem
ich bin übrigens fabian köster einnahmen
hätten dank jetzt wissen sie's nicht
aber sehr nett zurück ins studio ich
stelle ich mir ins wohnzimmer jährlich
das
fordert will
[Musik]
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich